翻訳: Riaki Poništ
校正: Hiroko Kawano
あなたの生ゴミを
野菜に変えるサービスを
私は作ります
でも あなたが地域に
生ごみを提供してくれないと
このサービスは始まりません
生ごみは 毎日捨てられてますが
見逃せないほど
栄養がたっぷりです
さらに 野菜が大きくなるような
窒素 リン カリ
微量要素が含まれ
野菜をおいしくしてくれます
そういった野菜が地域でできる
さらに 生ごみと連結する
地域で飼うニワトリやヤギ
そのような家畜の餌とつながる
100パーセント生ごみが
野菜と連結する
すごくないですか？
屋上のガーデンで 週末働く
夕食においしい野菜が並ぶ
さらに余った野菜を地域で配る
たくさんできたら地域で売る
そんな街に住みたいと思って
この活動を始めました
23年前 私の大好きな父が
がん宣告を受けました
余命３ヶ月
父は作家を目指して
公務員をしてました
父と話し合い
私たちが選んだのは
家に連れて帰って
無農薬を食べる —
無農薬の野菜を食べる
食養生
その日からチャレンジが
始まりました
すぐに 大きな壁にぶつかったんです
無農薬の野菜が手に入らない
毎日２時間かけて探した野菜が
値段が高くて
しなびているんです
父に食べさせないと
すぐ死んでしまうかもしれないという焦り
土が病んで
安全な食が手に入らないという怒り
もう毎日くたくたになりながら
２年間過ごしました
結果 父は亡くなったんですが
食べ物を変えただけで
命が２年延びたんです
このことは 私の人生の価値観を
大きく転換させました
本当に一番最初に思ったのは
食べ物そのものが
人の存在を左右するっていうこと
２つ目は 土が病んでいるという現状
３つ目は 私たちの暮らしが
自然の摂理と離れてしまっている
この３つのことです
その当時 私は０歳と２歳の
子どもを抱えた主婦でした
一緒に看病した母と
土が病んでる現状を調べました
知れば知るほど
知識が増えれば増えるほど
その土と私たちの暮らし
環境への複雑な関係が分かりました
本当にどうしていいのか
分からなかったんです
その頃同時に 母から
コンポストを習いました
[（英語）ダンボール箱でコンポスト]
コンポストは
毎日食べる私たちの生ごみを
消化してくれる箱だったんです
空気中から自然発生した微生物が
生ごみを栄養として獲得し
温度を上げながら
分解してくれます
電気も使わないのに
３ヶ月間毎日生ごみを入れて
合計50キロの生ごみが
この中で消化されていくんです
このことは
私のこれからの人生
それから
課題だと思った３つのことを
改善できるのではないか
というふうに思いました
父の看病をしているときに
子どもを連れて野菜を探し回った暮らしは
半径２キロでした
その当時 何もかもが自分ごととして
いろんなことを知り
いろんなことで喜び
いろんなことを考えました
すべてが自分ごとだったんです
この半径２キロと
コンポストをつなげば
いろんな問題が解決できるのではないか
土の改善と暮らしをつなげることができる
というふうに確信しました
母を誘って 仲間とNPO法人
循環生活研究所を立ち上げました
地域で 暮らしに必要な物が循環する
格好いい暮らしを目指して
まずはコンポストの普及を始めました
活動は全国に広がりました
多いときで とうとう講座を
年間400回もするようになりました
これでは 地域をよくする
暮らしに行けないということで
15年前に 人材育成に軸足を変えました
この20年間 コンポストで人生や価値観が
変わった人にたくさん出会えました
70歳の主婦が
コンポストでできた野菜で
レストランを起業しました
17歳の不登校の男の子が
コンポストと畑に出会って
毎日学校に来るようになり
卒業して 今 農家を目指して
頑張っています
自治体が
地域のコンポストを使って
大きなイベントで
花を咲かせようとしています
コンポストの魅力に
ずっと私はハマり続けています
コンポストの価値は
生ごみの栄養の合計だけではありません
コンポストの最大の魅力は 教育力です
毎年 幼稚園生や小学生に
コンポストを教えて
さまざまな効果を上げています
それは微生物の存在や
ごみが減ること
土が改善すること
おいしい野菜ができること
様々なことです
コンポストの初日
子どもたちは「クサい クサい」
と言って盛り上がります
大きな成果とともに
このことが１つ 気にかかり始めました
子どもたちの
においの表現の少なさです
子どもたちは１種類か２種類ぐらいしか
「クサい」という表現ができないんです
子どもたちと
コンポストを１ヶ月しました
子どもたちに
大きな変化が見られたんです
「くさい」という表現が
20倍から30倍膨らみました
このことから 私たちは子どもたちの
今の暮らしの現状を知るんです
子どもたちは 今
冷暖房設備の効いた部屋にいて
窓を開けることが少なくなりました
外で遊ぶ時間も減りました
近くに公園や広場が減りました
においの感覚や
表現 季節に触れて
季節のにおいを嗅ぐことも減ったんです
コンポストは
子どもの五感を育むこと
様々な社会問題を解決できるのではないか
という可能性を感じました
このように広がってきた
コンポストですが
大きな挫折を感じました
それは 私たちの活動は
アジアまで広がり
何十倍にも広がったんですが
世の中的に考えると
まだ数パーセントの人しか
私たちの活動に取り組んでいない
ということです
このままでは 23年前に描いた
私の住みたい街に近づくのには
あと何年かかるのか
分からなかったんです
そのことに気づいたときに
近所の人が
「いい活動してるね 頑張ってね」
と言ってることが
「いい活動してるね
あなた頑張ってね　私はしませんけど」
というふうに聞こえたんです
「そんな ひねくれちゃダメだ」
というふうに自分で思ったんですが
それほど 私には衝撃でした
もう一度 素直な気持ちになって
考え直すと
「どうして参加しないのか
私に見えない壁は何なのか」
ということを考えました
それは いつでも誰でも取り組める
そういった活動が
地域にあるっていうこと
それを半径２キロの範囲で
広げるっていうことが
大事だっていうことが分かりました
私の言う「半径２キロ」は
主婦が感じる生活圏
さらに 地産地消の定理
ニホンミツバチの行動範囲
高齢者のデイケアサービスの
送迎サービスの範囲
いろんなことが
つながってきました
この範囲でコンポストをして
さらに 畑をつなげる
マーケットをつなげる
これをパイロットモデルとして
10年近くしました
それだけでは足りなかったんです
コンポストをしていても
隣の人がしている
誰がしているっていうのは分からないんです
コンポストをコミュニティ化することが
大切だということが分かりました
コンポストを 若者が
おしゃれな自転車で回収して街を走り回る
こういった計画を立てたんです
さらに 長くするのではなくて
短期間に回収交換する
サービスを考えました
畑もコミュニティ化しました
そのコミュニティガーデンでは
様々な教育活動を受けることができます
循環する技術を学べるんです
それからマーケットも
自分で育てた野菜が販売できる
地域の人が買いに来る
そういうふうにコミュニティ化しました
この仕組みが
「ローカル・フード・サイクリング」です
半径２キロで
自分たちの台所を起点とした
栄養サイクルが回る
これを住民が
自分の手で回すんです
こういった活動が広がると
ごみが減量して
焼却コストが減ります
私たちの住む市では
30パーセントの人が取り組めば
11.5億の税金が削減できます
さらに フードマイレージも
削減できます
この活動で健康になれば
医療費の削減も夢ではありません
お金の使い方が
地域で変わっていくんです
半径２キロでの循環の経済を考えれば
この中で若者が働き
様々なアイディアを出していきます
今日もコンポスト・クルーが
街を走ってきました
[（英語）あなたのライフスタイルが
あなたの未来を変える]
私たちの未来は 私たちの今日の
ライフスタイルで変わります
あなたは何を選択しますか
ありがとうございます
（拍手）